hello and welcome to this video playing
gay grandmaster glamorous with that ego
kovalenko wow now that's a very strong
player right isn't he why am i confusing
things it's very strong i think if you
look it up but i think it's very high
rated anyway let's see what happens some
c4 and c5
now get some oh interesting patiently 6m
yeah why not why not huh okay I don't
want to play 92 here but night b5 also
looks wrong huh yeah maybe I made some
stick there already I don't know ok
[ __ ] I couldn't beforehand but it's
not so bad he doesn't have an easy night
you five there ok Mickey 322 why start
working why is that move working tell me
I should lose stuff peace or queen for
some material
ok hmm can still just continues okay
shooting for some stuff on the Kings
side okay if you don't if you absolutely
don't want to resign it's probably
something i'd share that that's what you
have to try okay you're here black
forfeits due to disconnection hmm okay
yeah well can you do everybody bluntness
a piece yet there it was just yeah not
much to say this is a kind of a normal
position I think they normally go to f3
here right anyway it looked kind of
normal here or this I'm not super happy
with this 90 to cover off the c-4 porn
but what can you do it still looks
fairly normal however well yeah this is
just blunders blunders everything okay
not much the same it's just a blunder
over peace it happens to all of us here
even a strong GM I think that guys is
very high rated I want to check that
just briefly nized his to 680 I just
checked in the reading list so we see
that even absolute top player second
blunder peas and blitz so don't worry if
it happens to you it happens to all of
us okay well thanks for watching